The vitamin D level was tested last December and was found to be in the low 40s.
I started taking one ADK avail almost every day last December.
It was retested again just recently and it's still in the low 40s, no improvement.
So ADK avail has 5,000 IU's of vitamin D in it per capsule, if I remember correctly.
So a friend of mine suggested that I switch to a liquid version of vitamin D that might absorb it better in your thoughts.
I don't think you're going to absorb it better because you're actually taking a gel cap that breaks out into liquid immediately too.
So it's not that.
I think it's the dosage.
So I don't know what your VDR gene looks like that's your vitamin D receptor gene picture looks like I'd have to pull up your genetic profile again.
If a person has defects on their VDR genes, they have a much more difficult time utilizing an absorbed vitamin D.
If again, if your HCl production hydrochloric acid production, your stomach is low, you're going to have a difficult time absorbing any supplements.
Number three, if your gallbladder is compromised at all, either gallstones, I have my gallbladder removed or I don't even know that I have gallstones, I have sluggish gallbladder, whatever.
You're going to have a difficult time absorbing the fat soluble vitamins.
So if you have low vitamin D levels and you're taking vitamin D and you can't get the vitamin D levels up, those are some of the things you need to look at.
What about vitamin D receptors genetically look like?
If they have carbohydrates, you have defects either a single or especially a double allele defect on your VDR gene, then you have to just increase the dosage.
Number two, do I have a decreased hydrochloric acid production and decreased hydrochloric acid?
Is that causing a bowel absorption? So it could be a bowel absorption issue.
Number three, do I have gallbladder issues and a decrease in bile production, bile is what you need to absorb fat and break down the fats?
The A, the vitamin A, the vitamin D, the vitamin K and the vitamin E are all fat soluble vitamins indeed bile in order for you to be able to utilize them correctly and to get proper absorption.
So those are the things that you want to look at. That's why I like that clear balance.
Sorry, sorry, sorry. That's why I like the clear digest, the digestive enzyme that we have private labeled as cutters, clinic, clear digest because it has, I was just telling a dust of this today, I think.
And as HCl in it, it has a good balance of enzymes for breakdown of proteins and carbohydrates and fats and it has ox bile.
It's the only digestive enzyme that I've seen. There's probably others on the market that have all three of those things. You need HCl in order to digest food in your stomach.
Otherwise, that's going to go into your, into your duodenum, only partially digested and you're totally, totally sent yourself on for HCl infections.
You need digestive enzymes to take pressure off your, your pancreas to help you digest anything in your food. And then how many people have sluggish gold letters? I mean, lots.
So adding that ox bile is certainly a huge help for a lot of people. So if you even, you know, people that have no, so a person has no gold letters that are gone better removed, then you definitely, you can go right to that and you need more than what's in the clear digest, you need ox bile.
So get an ox bile supplement. We have them in the store that effect. I think we have several that are near expiration date that I'll throw. I know who asked this question. I think it's them and I will throw a model of that in your next order.
I want to remind Megan so I don't forget to remind her.
Because taking just taking one of those with your supplements could be the solution and you don't even need to increase the amount of vitamin that you're taking.